see y'all please get your hands up
turn around and get on the ground
get on the ground right there
shouldn't everyone we have uh our
suspects running
[Applause]
get on the ground
get your hands behind your back
do not reach
[Applause]
stay
on the ground
[Applause]
get over here
turn around
what's your name
all right come on let's get up
thank you guys
thanks for that stay over
here
come on come on come on come on oh is it
metal
no it's yellow jackets everywhere dude
come on man yeah we gotta grab him and
go
come on
here I got him from this
bro
water
I have epipens if someone needs it now
well can I get you some water pressure
just sit down right there we're trying
to switch on the beach you understand
that hey hey water water I got water